what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we're going to watch the next episode
of The Last of Us of course joined by my incredibly
sexy handsome beautiful gorgeous friend Andrew
the Gordon Igor 7-Eleven hello beautiful that
was uh that was nice I know you understood
that reference ladies and gentlemen you know
what to do leave a like on this video I want
to say thank you to everyone who's been watching
our videos uh it means the world it means
a lot to have everyone here but before we
go into that reaction we do have a sponsor
today a sponsor who I intentionally wanted
to shout out on the Last of Us video because
these are the perfect items for anyone to
survive in the middle of an apocalypse or
if you just want to be a cool Woodsman and
that is the company bespoke you know bespoke
is Andrew let me tell you bespoke post is
a monthly membership club delivering a box
of awesome top shelf goods from under the
radar Brands it's free to join and you can
skip a month or cancel at any time so every
month they introduce members to cool new products
uh talking outdoor gear Hardware home and
kitchen goods clothing and more even live
oysters you're always asking me about live
oysters Andrew and it's all based on a preference
quiz that they fill out so 90 of the products
that come from small Brands I like small Brands
Andrew I hope you do too many of which are
based right here in the US of a that's where
we live Andrew every box of awesome has around
70 worth of goods inside but costs you only
a fraction of the value now I got three boxes
myself Andrew I got three boxes myself I saw
this on the bespoke side I said I want that
throwing knives that's right baby look at
that it comes with a full grain leather sheath
they're throwing knives for any skill level
18 by 18 tough targets face this one I saw
too because I was like this would really come
in handy it's an mh10 headlamp it helps you
not be afraid to hike at night when you're
lost in the darkness Greg look for the light
oh you tied it in thank you Andrew and the
last one this is one that I was like for a
guy who goes on road trips quite a lot I really
needed this one almost as much as I needed
throwing knives A Day Tripper cooler bag and
it comes with a stainless steel bottle opener
as well you'll be able to preview your box
of Ford shift what I mean by that is you'll
get a box of awesome assigned to you and before
it's shipped you'll get a preview of what's
to come inside to decide if you'd like to
one keep it two swap it for a different box
or three skip the month entirely for no charge
you only pay for what you want so to get 20
off your first box of awesome click the link
in the description box and at checkout use
the code real rejects 20. or go to bespoke.com
real rejects 20. thank you to bespoke for
sponsoring this video
foreign
good for you guys
holy God
holy God [Music] oh these are uh these are
Hunters
oh is this the night they escaped whoa
he's hearing impaired either they're just
being silent just because I don't want to
get caught did it feel good the train your
neighbors to Federal how does it make you
feel now and they really give a villain to
the hunters huh we could put you on trial
you're all guilty so that's how that'll go
and you'll do something do something easy
where is Henry
I guess they don't know kill them he's with
edel's Team oh man hey I want our people going
door to door no oh I'm sorry how long do you
think we should wait should we wait a day
or two should we wait a week door-to-door
take a lot of men and there are other things
he's not my seventh priority Perry come on
Perry get with the program we are not really
putting them on trial when you're done burn
the bodies it's bad oh damned well losing
a family member uh can do that to you I guess
foreign
they're gonna die before they get to meet
Ellie [Laughter] scared yeah of course he
is he's scared because you're scared
he's always had to protect him oh the gay
music
foreign
just always properly know when to insert the
music from the game
I like seeing this because in the game like
Henry's just so Stern and disciplinary with
Sam to like keep him alive do you get to see
this really soft side
we must have overlapped at the previous episode
this is so smart that we're getting to spend
some time with Henry and Sam before they meet
Joel Nelly
speak sign language don't you I do my uh best
friend is
dealing with the reality yeah
I'll become a superhero
ah okay this makes sense
clever
oh man it's so much harder to survive in this
when you're hearing impaired yeah
foreign
from that angle
duck yeah I like the perspective ships
yeah goes specifically looking for them
glass
smart are you sure you're gonna hear it of
course I'll hear it that's the damn point
we don't want to hurt you we want to help
you
okay okay um
I don't know what the next step is with something
like this
you heard us right
that's right oh wow so weird it's all man
that's just the way he sounds he has an [__]
voice don't tell him he's okay everything's
great dude I can't read your tone man my name
is Henry My Brother Sam and Most Wanted Man
in Kansas City although right now my guesses
are running a close second yeah they already
think they're working together
I switched locations as they mentioned did
you get these from Bill
and she is how old is he [Laughter]
DJ oh that's young I'm Ellie you're like 12
in the game yeah something like I mean in
the game he said he was 14 and then Sam made
fun of him for saying that or Henry did
I mean
look [Laughter]
I saw what you did he killed those men never
killed anyone I'm pointing I know they're
gonna choose the closest I've ever come to
being violent my shoulder weight you clear
the way survived this long without killing
anyone not even infected
[Music] in a long time so how are we getting
now
uh definitely a change from the game no [__]
version we get close we get caught how do
we get across
it's a great plan so what do you need me for
oh that was infected just not on the surface
Frederick drove them underground 15 years
ago you see what I know is it's empty you've
been down there how do you know that no but
the federal guy that I worked with told me
that it's clean yeah what if there's more
or one of those blind ones that seems like
a bat wait you ran into a clicker the first
thing I call a clicker in the show yeah maybe
yeah if it gets bad down there we turn around
and run right back out the scene where we
can oh that's a great plan no that's my dicey
is plan but as far as I could tell
only shot I like him a lot he's great you're
saying they're going to help us Escape dope
right oh we also saw last episode what's possibly
under there goodness
[Music] I like this a lot it's extremely immediate
site I think it's his way I just love how
exhausted he is from running plays into the
age a lot more
I just got a smile on her face shoot something
[Music]
exciting episode damn
oh God yeah gee it's empty is good I wouldn't
risk talking we've been down here down here
don't know anything
about my dad
oh wow oh my God what a shot
really make the perspective feel like trapping
you know claustrophobic too yeah I could have
just said that
oh the amazing yeah oh my God just like
ah
nice nice attention to detail
yep yep
oh no way no way no way in dude I bet Ellie
would like that four five six eleven
ah so cool it's cute to the edge of the U
-verse and back endure survive [__] yeah
man it wouldn't be so bad to wait light out
a bit different that was when we pop back
out on the other side
you can tell he's not comfortable with that
yes
original
four and about me not killing someone yeah
yeah it was a man a great man and he's always
forgiving have you ever met someone like that
kind of man you'd follow anywhere
Sam you got sick leukemia there was one drug
that worked there wasn't much left of it belong
to Federal so I gave them something big
oh that one great man interest yeah I am the
bad guy because I did a bad guy thing when
you get it though you might not be her father
but you were someone's yeah
that's smart for many reasons that we can't
get into I will say yeah that's like all we're
gonna say Gamers know what we're talking about
that's all we'll say I do really like the
guy who's playing Henry though he's really
good feels very real yeah you feel the weight
of everything on his shoulders
we were together we would be safe
soft side to the coldness he was so beautiful
I'm not
never was the last time I saw him alive in
a jail he told me to forgive yeah where is
the Justice in that what is the point of that
very good question your brother was a great
man we all loved him he didn't change anything
you did that's why they follow you we're with
you
good it's interesting that without going into
any story details at all that they are carrying
over themes from the second game I was thinking
just that
oh so they they just made it through the tunnels
already yeah that was fast where are you gonna
go I don't know yet well we're going to Wyoming
what it's a huge state it can fit two more
people maybe we just call this one a success
and say our father was changed his mind this
is how it goes he's like no L.A nervous and
then I'm like I'm gonna ask you a million
more times [Music] a sniper yep
night time yep change the setting of the day
oh [__] guys you would know better Henry
come on if you don't move he's not gonna hit
you I'm gonna go around try to get nails through
the back and then I'll take them out but if
you go out there he's gonna kill you oh you
trust me
I love how worried Ellie got for him when
he said he was gonna move
the sound design that sniper is crazy he is
moving along briskly here look at him go
[Music]
just alone the sniper is waiting all night
[Music] oh as an old ass man ah Put the gun
down slide it over to me and then stay up
here for another hour this dude looks so familiar
please don't do it please
uh
it's got a sniper yeah that made a lot of
noise
no oh
I was like just please don't skip out on this
part yeah
why do you think you're in front clear them
oh my God they're gonna Mad Max this [__]
[Music]
holy God
yeah no need to shoot Ellie just kiss run
wow that is terrifying
no [Music] nicely done Joe [Applause] [Music]
damn look at that wreckage
holy crap [Music] whoa thank God that happened
ah
is that a rumble they've made so much noise
gosh she's such a pain in the ass she's not
the kids go oh no sorry I know why you did
what you did but did you ever stop to think
that maybe he was supposed to die man will
kids die Henry they die all the time
annoying
what's gonna happen it ends the way it ends
oh let's go [Music]
oh take your shot Joel
[Music] oh God that is scary
oh you can hear all of them
oh whoa
wow
there's so many
[Applause] [Music] nice yeah oh cool wow this
is chaotic as hell
oh deeper alive
foreign [Music] [Applause]
oh [Music]
is this it
whoa oh [Music] come on [Music]
oh man motor is gonna be right for him oh
oh goodbye Jeffrey Pierce probably watered
a gnarly death
oh my God is that a child it looks like it
come on Ellie you got a gun I think she's
out of ammo
where's Henry Sam okay
[Music] oh I love that POV perspective this
is great
what a scary ass situation of being oh [Applause]
damn man you gotta be a really confident shot
to make sure you don't shoot out where'd that
bloater go
this [__] woman man
uh oh
[Music] good oh there's the bloated
damn wow that is like a World War Z effect
whoa never in the game did we see that many
you didn't throw any spores
that was a night wasn't it it'll be okay easier
when you're a kid anyway is it you don't have
anybody else relying on you I guess you're
doing a good job then dear and survive that's
just redundant yeah it's not great look I
don't know exactly how I'm getting to Wyoming
I'm probably walking you know if you want
to yeah oh the bond oh it's like you're waiting
to hear that again
oh to line up look scared
this kid is a really good actor
scorpions
that's a fear but before the apocalypse people
have
um uh oh he's gonna tell her oh wow what a
change
wow my blood is medicine
oh this is so sad oh my God
it's worth a try
true
this is a really interesting angle oh that
is so heartbreaking
just wants to heal him
[Music] oh
this is even more gut-wrenching
amen promise
God damn you freaking invited them to my office
get everything
hey
laughs
holy [__] are you okay
what what did I do
oh my God
let me know
and Ally probably really thought it worked
too huh [__] just this whole world shattered
Henry
that that was harsh
which was West
kind of does feel out of Logan Hall
[Music]
s
oh boy what'd you think Andrew I'll just check
it out kick it off kicking them off you kick
it off I thought it was a really well paced
jumble of emotion episode where you know the
the tone was really well balanced and just
I mean there were moments of exhilaration
from the action to just more moments of heart
wrench and then moments of bond and I really
love the angle too I mean we're going to talk
about a lot of different things but I really
love the angle they went out with Sam and
Ellie I mean it was a little bit different
perspective to me how I felt in the game was
Sam kind of had a little bit of a crush on
Ellie and you know that was and that's at
least how I took it definitely um but I thought
the the talks in the game yeah oh yeah that
too um but I thought this was really unique
you know having him being hearing impaired
and you know they had more of a a older sister
little brother type of bond and I just it
was very heartfelt and I really appreciated
the chemistry between uh belly and and salmon
I thought they the scenes were just so emotional
on I also love how you pointed out to that
you know Henry had a little bit because in
the game he's very he's very Stern very strict
understandably so he doesn't want anything
to happen to say I'm in a post-apocalyptic
world we can all understand that but seeing
the softer side of their relationship I I
thought it was really endearing and I appreciated
seeing that but there were just a lot of different
things I know you mentioned that Kathleen
was very annoying and I agree there were moments
where I'm like damn it why do you keep interrupting
here and I get it but I I did think you know
they did a good job of at least making me
feel empathetic towards her I mean I I did
feel for her I I feel terrible that you know
Sam had to do the make the moral decision
like hey um do I give up this man that I that
I really deeply care for and respect and you
know he's a big part of this resistance movement
that's going to help us from fedra but it's
to save you know my world my my brother which
I'm not going to go into possible foreshadowing
but um I I just think it was a really interesting
moral dilemma to give us that something from
the game we didn't really get to see much
of from Henry I mean was just more of uh hey
let's go out of this uh let's get out of Pittsburgh
situation I'm gonna do whatever it takes to
save my brother that's the extent of what
we got from Henry in in the game so I think
they gave you know they made him a much more
in my opinion three more uh three-dimensional
character in in this episode and I really
appreciated you know the layers that they
gave this character and I thought the actor
who played I mean I think all the actors did
a great job in this episode the actor who
played Henry he was great you could see how
broken he was from the decision he had to
make but you know again you could empathize
with his decision because he was saving his
brother's life so I just I thought they did
a lot of really interesting angles and we
got him in bloater yeah that was freaking
awesome oh man they really nailed it with
that I know it was a little sad that he didn't
throw the spores or whatever but whatever
I mean it was it was so cool to see him bloated
in live action that was awesome but yeah no
I mean this was a great episode and also seeing
you know the belly and Joel uh relationship
getting more fleshed out I really appreciate
that just again little nuances and moments
like where you know the sniper is cornering
them and Joel is saying I'm gonna go around
here and now he's like no no you could get
hit like just little things like that it just
adds a big you know layer to their relationship
and I like how it's slowly being fleshed out
it's just ah I'm so invested in those two
they're so good together yeah I mean like
the The Last of Us video game the first one
is pretty short yes for a video game in comparison
to the second one too yeah but it's still
longer than Nine episodes of Television will
be you know what I mean yeah like it's still
going to be longer than that um because so
much of the storytelling does advance as part
of the game like if you only watch just the
cutscenes their story that's intertwined in
diet like a lot of the dialogue where you're
like that's what they say in the game it's
probably that's happening while you're doing
gameplay a lot of the time so you know it's
like you can't like Infuse everything uh into
here understandably so and I think that the
you know the themes that they leave with that
resonate so strong of you know the the consequences
of what we do for love and you know they start
talking about forgiveness here and so much
of this of the world of loss of us it just
primarily I think deals with with the topic
of consequences you know uh like having this
thing with Henry where he he made a choice
um and now there's just massive consequences
to it you know and the the ultimate it's so
it's just so so loud
for sure to have you know because it's like
of course I remembered that in in the game
obviously you know yeah uh Sam does get um
attacked and he does but he keeps it a secret
yeah and I like this and then and then Henry
ends up having to kill his brother and then
um we'll say unalives himself because YouTube's
sensitive about a certain word uh but the
way I went down here did have a little bit
more of a realistic approach um but yeah it
does have it has that thing about it I I I
I think that you know drugman sometimes likes
to refuse them how can we break their hearts
more of hey let's have Joe welcome them to
go to Wyoming the moment before we learn that
Sam's infected hey let's see yeah Sam will
keep infected but let's have him tell Ellie
and have Ellie hope that her blood will actually
cure this guy that was a really interesting
angle I'd love that yeah it add it does add
that Dimension to it um because yeah you in
the it's it it this show has an interesting
contrasts uh to to the game because in some
ways you spend more time with Henry and Sam
in the game but in a lot of ways you get to
know Henry and Sam a lot more in the show
Absolutely within the this one hour episode
that they have so it's it's very it's very
interesting how they do that because let's
no no no no I was listening no I felt like
you wanted to say something I want you to
be able to say stuff Andrew no no no keep
going keep going all right I think I'll keep
going anyway yeah they have so so I like what
they're doing with Henry and I liked what
they did with Henry and Sam here a lot and
how like the encounters that Joel has I think
there's like a a I think the arc you guys
obviously even if you haven't played the game
I think the the obvious Arc of Joel getting
in touch with his fatherhood side while bonding
with Ellie is extremely apparent even if you
haven't played right you just spoiled it for
me man you know like that's that's obvious
um and what I'm liking is this sort of uh
Nomad approach that the show's taking well
this Wanderer where as you're on the roads
of travels you have an encounter like oh he
gets this letter from Bill and that affects
him and that kind of plays into that Arc he
encounters Henry and Sam and through dialogue
exchanges that he has there that affects him
that it plays into that Arc and I think that's
really neat how they develop that because
you don't have as much time as a game so they
find ways of okay well how can we make certain
scenes more substantial so that way we can
still have that desired effect that we're
looking for because I did have I did I did
fine I I've never in the it took five episodes
for me to get here um five in total where
I found myself going ah you skipped over some
stuff that I really would have liked to have
seen in live action the tunnel scene I mean
yeah the the tunnel scene and uh just just
some like overall sneaking sequences you know
like there's it's like significantly more
complex um you know when he's having to sneak
to the sniper yeah yeah yeah like a whole
bunch of people and stuff yeah I'm like okay
you kind of just like like ran back there
it got up there yeah you know uh and so I
I do um I I do find myself um that I do find
my that was the one this was the first episode
where I would find myself actually thinking
that way more than the bill and Frank episode
because for some reason I think it's because
in the bill and Frank episode there was almost
like nothing that was from the kid so it didn't
really uh make me think about the game when
I was watching that episode whereas here there
were stuff where I was like really thinking
about the game and then I found myself kind
of missing some stuff that they skipped out
on so it does have to be a little bit of a
mental check for myself to go that's different
that's the game this is the show how is the
show doing it and I thought show was handling
it really well because I actually think the
the way the sequence went like when he shot
um when Henry had to kill his brother here
uh this I like how they they he doesn't have
time to think about it you know it it they
don't play into this like big rumination conflict
of like what do I do what do I do what do
I do it's just like such a fraught tense situation
that is just it's like it's all off Instinct
in that moment and you shoot and then and
then it's a realization of like what have
I done which is kind of like how it does in
the game but it but it's it's played it was
something I felt more realistic to me in this
scenario um so yeah I think that they they
really hit it here the thing with the one
thing I'll say is the thing with Kathleen
there's just something about her that I wasn't
truly interested in and I and I have no idea
like it was one of those things where yeah
I I you're doing all the things that I would
like a show to do if you're bringing in this
character and you're you're flushing them
out you're giving them more Humanity you're
giving them more layers it was this weird
thing for me where I just I found myself going
I feel like on paper everything to make me
click with this idea of having this character
here and what you're doing should make me
interested in her but I'm really not I have
no idea why I I just wasn't in tune I don't
know if it was the performance I don't like
the dog performers but I don't know if it
was the performance um it it just was something
that I preferred it when you would just check
in with her and she was like just a villain
and and uh like the the with it with the um
with the tinge of humanity like the last episode
where you could tell like oh this is rooted
in the pain of losing her brother yeah yeah
like that that stuff but I did really like
that scene though with her and Jeffrey Pierce
explaining about you know the forgiveness
and her brother and all that and saying I
don't care about that because it does play
a lot into some themes that I can't go into
with foreshadowing about revenge and losing
your humanity and just what that can do to
you so I did you know from that perspective
it was told Neil druckman told The Last of
Us I appreciated from that perspective but
I I hear what you're saying you're just more
used to seeing her as a stalker for Charlie
Sheen on Two and a Half Men yeah it must be
like you're not funny what's going on yeah
no I mean but that's the thing with that it
was that scene when it really hit me when
I'm like I really feel like I should be more
interested in what's happening but I kind
of just want to cut back to the other stuff
right now yeah fair enough yeah fair enough
fair enough but uh and to your point I do
find her believable I I mean if I have to
be really honest like I I guess I just didn't
find her all that believable no there were
there were points too where I was agreeing
with you was a little like this character
is annoying but again I I understood her motivations
I I could sympathize with her I get where
she's coming from I can't say you know if
someone again we know that uh Henry didn't
murder her brother but he basically like laid
him out in the lamb you know to to fedra so
I I get where her anger stems from my I could
understand that from a character perspective
but I get what you're saying there were just
times where like all right I'm I'm kind of
done with this checked out I just wanna I
just want to go back to Henry Sam Joel and
and belly and let's let's get let's get hopefully
a bloater in here somewhere so I I could sympathize
with what you're saying but um to what you
were saying earlier you made a really good
point because we definitely got it felt like
at least in the video game when it comes to
Sam and Henry we got to spend more time with
them at least because there's an extended
tunnel sequence that we got like maybe five
minutes here yeah and then sneaking around
the guards and yeah yeah but so I I get you're
totally right when it comes to that but again
I I appreciate that we got more character
moments we got to know them more and that's
what I I loved what I've loved that whole
tunnel sequence hell yeah probably would have
cost a lot of money too to to include those
sequences so I I get where they're they're
taking shortcuts and I appreciate what Neil
druckman said like hey if it makes sense in
our story we're gonna stick exactly at the
game for the most part if it if it's something
that we can improve upon we're gonna do that
and for the most part they've pretty much
nailed that down and I've loved everything
that they've included or got rid of um I I
can appreciate what you're saying in terms
of that snipe because in the game that's sniper
sequence there's so much ten I mean when you
got just the few guys coming out after you
and then that's I mean it takes a good five
to ten minutes even if you're really good
at that game to to get in there and I'm not
saying we needed to spend that much time yeah
in the in the game you are you're Joel and
you're you're and you're trying to get Henry
Sam and Ellie to get to you yeah and you have
to keep shooting down bad guys I keep coming
yeah but I mean again I I do like the changes
overall throughout the uh what is that five
episodes we watched throughout the five episodes
I think they've made smart changes and expanded
where they need to and again the whole angle
of I still love the episodes
if you have I'm not calling nitpicks but it's
things that like hey I just I was thinking
about this in the game no it's fair what you're
making Fair points and you know yeah it's
better to be the only one yeah yeah no no
for sure but uh and I mean the action like
finally we got a really action-packed episode
I mean I know we got at the beginning of episode
four we got to see uh Joel and belly like
uh unloading on on the uh Hunters but the
action we got like I mean at least for me
I don't remember ever in the game that many
amount of infected coming at once so well
it's like they I like that because it was
like a hive mind was just building up in there
just waiting to break out yeah and so it's
like a cool crescendo yeah and it's I like
the ironic part of it was these guys who pushed
them all under the tunnels and now it's come
back to swallow yeah and we saw that foreshadowing
obviously at the uh at the at some point in
the last episode we saw the rumble and we're
like oh is that what we think it is yeah so
and because she didn't prepare for it yeah
yeah no it makes sense came back to eat her
alive yeah at literally and figures and the
imagery too I don't know maybe I'm crazy I
mean I am crazy but uh the imagery reminded
me a lot of Steven Summers uh the mummy and
The Mummy Returns when the scarabs just come
out like you said it just reminded me a lot
of that so but no overall great episode um
I really liked the two actors who played Henry
and Sam that was uh I just was I mean obviously
I was already emotionally invested in the
characters from the game but obviously different
things seeing him on the TV show and right
away in one episode is hooked I love the way
they inserted the non-linear storytelling
from the beginning back to their perspective
from what was happening in the last episode
it reminded me yeah it remind me me a lot
of Man of Steel and Batman v Superman the
end of Man of Steel and then seeing it from
Bruce Wayne's perspective at the beginning
of Batman vs Superman just seeing those different
perspectives uh intersecting intertwining
rather so I thought that was a really neat
and interesting touch but overall yeah I love
this episode it really did a good job of just
balancing so many different things you felt
exhilarated from the action you felt really
heartbroken and gut-wrenched from not only
what happened to uh to Sam and Henry but like
you could tell with belly that it really like
not only broke her a little bit that she just
like she just started bonding not only with
Sam and Henry but she thought like she had
something that could save him and then just
the the heart wreck of no not being able to
so it's just oh she feels like she's got to
have more of a purpose to what's happening
absolutely so I just I thought this this episode
just did a great job of hitting on so many
different levels from action to emotion to
heartbreak to it was just and really well
paced it was just a very exhilarating episode
that I really appreciated and loved I know
the trailer without gonna be very careful
I know the trailer show because they mentioned
the character Riley in the first episode and
I know the trailer shows you Riley um like
she's created on IMDb uh so you know you gotta
see what's happened with Riley what was that
whole story right like they gotta explore
that at some point in the show and I'm trying
to figure out how to formulate my words and
saying this I think like the the story of
Riley that they hinted at in the first one
um in the first episode it was neat to see
that they that they still infused the whole
thing of Henry uh Sam and and Ellie bonding
and it kind of reminds me of what I remember
from the stuff with Riley and Gabe that's
also I guess that's the best not spoiler away
I'm just I don't know you know what I mean
I don't know how to formulate without spoiling
so I'm just gonna say I agree with you yeah
yeah but yeah and and
because of that that even added to a layer
for that that was one of the crazy benefits
of having played the game is because of that
that even makes the bonding with um you know
uh Sam even more heartbreaking uh yeah that's
all I don't know about it guys that was I
gotta tell you that was beyond entertaining
watching Greg like just really carefully how
do I want to say this without really spoiling
too much that was good that was that was hard
I know we got to explain I know we got to
be careful because we've already been accused
a few times of spoiling stuff just from the
most ridiculous things but yeah but no it's
it's um this this this in particular one was
great and um yeah I don't understand why Perry
I look at Perry the Perry that um Jeffrey
Pierce yeah you just just run and it's just
like that loader's coming for me I'm gonna
run dude come on Jeffrey Pierce is like I
gotta have a an epic death by bloater I meant
it felt like that kind of thing where it's
like if I'm gonna be a new show you better
give me an epic death yeah for sure but it
was no from a character's perspective like
it's a damn bloater like run dude run oh yeah
it's like dude run or throw some fire at one
of the two um but uh yeah I'm like he's gonna
get rid of you in a second like if you're
not like buying her much time um and yeah
and yeah that was that was crazy that was
a crazy sequence it was a cool Crescendo of
of sort of a whole array of all these kind
of crazy things but yeah no and just really
quick from the that final trailer we got where
we got to see the bloater and we saw a few
infected like coming out from from the uh
from the fire of that house I I didn't think
there was going to be this many infected so
that was a nice yeah yeah there was a night
there were a lot of nice surprises in this
episode so I was just I was really happy uh
from a gamer perspective and from just good
damn uh episode of Television I was really
happy I do think that sometimes even I think
even from like a television stamp even it
sometimes it is a little bit challenging to
assess um like the only thing we do is be
honest about it sometimes it can be a challenging
to assess like how would I feel about this
moment if like without the game right um because
it sometimes it does feel like there were
parts of the pacing that did feel off to me
at times during this episode and I'm not and
the thing is like I'm not entirely sure if
it's just because I'm like it just feel like
a cut down version of what I know I think
that's what it was because I I was kind of
thinking in my head okay wow the tunnel sequence
was really cut down and then the going right
to the sniper there's like build up to stuff
and yeah and then there's not much tension
and yeah and then it's like there's this whole
swarm of people then they just find a place
to like it just cuts to them they're hiding
someplace you know I get what I get what you're
saying because sometimes I get the impression
this show has the approach of like I don't
want any fat no fat here no fat like no [__]
here like no fat at and then there are other
times I'm like well now I feel like we kind
of just skip to the scene or or or just rush
to this moment but it was only in this episode
where I felt that at like certain points right
it's not like the whole thing yeah it's like
very very minimal at certain points but yeah
because I did I found it interesting when
you made the comment when they were outside
after the song like oh they're out of the
tunnel oh okay yeah we're outside okay okay
we're at the sniper scene all right yeah yeah
okay yeah yes even the sniper scene kind of
went fast like oh they introduced this whole
thing I was like I'm wondering like okay if
I was just watching this without the game
without the game like from a I I feel like
I would feel the same way honestly especially
even in the sniper scene like that went by
pretty fast and he kind of got up there pretty
like oh this is a problem no not really he
kind of just like right to the left and ran
up no for sure in the game it felt like not
an impossible test but you really felt the
danger of the situation not that we didn't
feel the danger here it felt like the Avengers
fighting Ultron just felt really easy yeah
that that seemed like he's like it's dark
it's not a problem it just it literally just
like a minute later he's up there yeah um
and so yeah there were there were parts of
this where I I did feel like this episode
for some reason that had some the most the
times when I was most aware of the editing
yeah when I haven't had that at all actually
at all with the with the first four episodes
yeah um so yeah this was this is the one where
I like while I love the episode still this
was the first episode of the of the five where
I was like I'm finding some for somebody like
have a little bit of a little bit of criticisms
uh for for things or things that just didn't
really jive with me um but yeah but we still
loved it guys that doesn't mean we didn't
love it yeah but I'm like I have some I have
some qualms and I would like to address them
in this particular episode because that's
what we're here yeah um but yeah guys uh leave
your thoughts down below what did you think
about the episode did you think it was perfect
um did uh what what did you love what did
you not love tell us tell everyone um last
but not least uh let's end this with a
Michael B Omni media ladies and gentlemen
I happen to know that this guy this guy is
a as a great friend of mine and uh he's someone
who I'd like to join the reject Nation by
the way I'd like him to just be part of the
channel but he lives in Virginia so we're
trying to sort some things out that's a real
thing that we're working on putting it out
there to the public why well go check out
his channel Omni media fantastic reaction
Channel he's covering the Rocky movies he's
never seen them before I haven't either what
yep only Rocky Balboa that's the only one
I've seen that's where you start and then
you kind of just throw out some names in a
hat and you go I guess I'm watching Rocky
3 next yeah exactly exactly um he's doing
that he's doing the last of us and he covers
a whole bunch of things and he really knows
his [__] and so I really think that if
you like if you like reaction channels uh
Michael B is someone who I I think deserves
a lot more recognition and uh he's great at
what he does his commentary is on point is
that anything point so I would really love
it if you guys made it this far yeah go show
support to Michael B all right guys omnimedia
is his YouTube channel it spells it o m n
one weird way to spell it you'd be in the
search more because everyone's typing it on
anyway all right see ya [Music]